I am so surprised because we just got in
the new 2020 MacBook Pro and not the
base model this is the one with Intel's
tenth generation CPUs this was supposed
to come next Friday and then it was said
that's gonna arrive on Tuesday once it
shipped and it just came today so I
don't know if we're the only ones that
got early but we are gonna be doing some
benchmarks and some thermal tests and
the CPU isn't in any other laptop on the
market it's brand spanking new exclusive
to Apple so we want to see how does this
thing perform how are the fans the heat
and you know overall how is this thing
gonna run so let's go ahead and open up
the box this looks like just any other
MacBook Pro from the previous years of
course it is a little bit Viktor just
slightly because of that new magic
keyboard that is a huge huge improvement
from the butterfly keyboard let's do
this quick unboxing so you can't tell a
difference at all looks identical weight
wise I can't tell a difference either
and the keys they do stick out a bit
more and they feel way better
so as I'm setting this up I want to let
you guys know that we also have the base
model 2020 MacBook Pro so if you guys
want to see a direct head-to-head
comparison in terms of performance
speakers SSDs cooling and let me tell
you that there are some big differences
make sure you guys hit that subscribe
button you guys enables notifications
because we will have a nice detailed
video letting you guys know which one
you should buy so we're all set up here
let's go ahead and jump right in and I
want to do an SSD test let's go ahead
and get started with black magic disk
speed test and right we have 2300 and
read a little bit under 2000 let's let
it run again and right now on the screen
you guys can see the performance of last
year's models so the write speed
actually went up by close to double
that's a big difference the read speed
now we're getting over 2000 it actually
went down a little bit which is
interesting now one difference is this
is the base model of eighteen hundred
dollar one I think most people are going
to be best off buying this base without
upgrading it and the SSD that now comes
with it is 512 gig instead of 256 now
the RAM also sixteen gig
instead of eight gigs so in the past
there wasn't that much of a difference
between the base model with two federal
three ports and the four Thunderbolt 3
port model now Apple made a much bigger
difference and effectively that makes it
a four hundred dollar price drop if you
wanted to get 16 gigs and 512 SSD most
reviewers are not mentioning that so
let's go ahead and close Blackmagic disk
speed test and open up Geekbench 5 I'm
gonna go ahead and start out the CPU
test and you guys can see we have the
i-5 with the g7 graphics now the tension
chips those are very important they are
10 nanometer they're more efficient and
Apple has a chip that only they are
using right now both I 5 and the i7 only
Apple has access to that this one starts
at 2 gigahertz base clock
whereas on other laptops like the Dell
XPS which we will also compare this
laptop to make sure you guys are subbed
that has a 1.5 gigahertz processor i7 so
this I 5 should be faster now CPUs are
important but what is more important is
graphics performance and we will be
testing out graphics along with some
gaming as well and there we have it here
are the scores we have 12 13 for single
core and 43 19 for multi-core keep in
mind this is the i-5 that's 2.0
gigahertz and if we compare it to last
year's I 5 that came with it that was a
2.4 gigahertz higher frequency for the
base but that one actually got 3907 so
that means that this new tension gets
about 10% higher score and Geekbench 4
with that lower clock now what matters
way more than that is the single core
score we have 12 13 last year's one
actually got 952 that means that this
new 2020 model has about 30% higher
single core score and not just makes it
much snappier day-to-day now let's move
on to graph mix and some of you guys
said that the i-5 probably doesn't come
with the best graphics you need to spend
the extra money on the i7 but as you
guys can see even the i-5 comes with a
g7 graphics that's the best one you can
get and that is excellent let's go ahead
and run this metal test and the score is
nine thousand eight hundred and seventy
seven now that might not mean
until we open up the previous model that
got 5628 so that is roughly 75% faster
for this new graphic ship and that's
really where we're seeing a difference
10% on multi-core 30% in single core and
75% more in graphics and keep in mind
the graphics card wasn't maxed out the
majority of that test
let's open up Unigine heaven and see how
that relates when we're really pushing
it I'm going to be using the extreme
preset all right and we have an FPS of
13.5 that is about 30% higher than the
previous MacBook Pro and what is
interesting is during this test as well
I never saw the GPU usage going above
about 75% where in the past it was maxed
out and if we look at the temperatures
we're at 74 degrees Celsius very low if
I mute the Mac it's silent you can't
hear the fans at all so it's running
cool I don't know what is going on why
the graphics isn't being maxed out we're
gonna have to take a deeper dive and
figure out what's happening for our full
review so you guys make sure you guys
don't miss that either way we do have an
improvement here now I want to go ahead
and run another graphics test and final
cut to see the difference in rendering
with the graphics so in front of me I
have the Bruce X benchmark for final cut
this is gonna test the graphics for
rendering let's go ahead and hit save
and we'll see how this does hopefully
it's going to use all of the graphics
okay this is very interesting the
graphics processor isn't even being used
halfway so maybe these new chips need
optimization with Mac OS or something
but we are moving along fairly quickly
so far we're at 26 27 seconds and done
38 seconds
comparing it to the last year's model it
took a minute in 17 seconds and actually
the base one was slightly faster for
some reason a minute and 12 this is 38
seconds and the graphics wasn't even
half used when we were doing this text
so we're not pushing it to the limit
that is a massive difference and that is
where you're gonna notice the
performance improvements of the new 10
generation processors and those graphics
that
literally twice as fast 38.5 and the
other ones a minute 17 wow so if you're
somebody's gonna do video editing where
do you get that much of a performance
game usually CPUs are just a small boost
very impressed and I'm glad we tested
this out with a more real-world test and
now it's time for our thermal test and
also performance tests cuz we only saw a
10% difference in terms of the
multi-core this is Cinnabon char 20 it's
gonna push all the course to their
limits and what we're gonna see here is
what Apple chose to do these tension
ships are supposed to be more efficient
but that's if you're not pushing more
power to them and we'll see if Apple
decided to push more power or maybe run
the fans hotter this time around I have
Intel power gadget open let's go ahead
and click run and we're gonna be
monitoring what is happening and right
off the bat it hit 40 watts and now
we're running at 39 watts apple is
definitely using more wattage previously
it would hit around 30 or so so Apple is
pushing these tension ships hard you
guys see we're at a hundred degrees
Celsius almost instantly Apple is trying
to max out the performance with this
machine running at 3 gigahertz right now
why did just starting to come down and
fans are starting to spin up so far it's
been about 45 seconds our fans are at
4700 still running warm but the CPU
dipped a 2.84 a bit and back up to 2.9
wattage is that 28 Apple up 3 gigahertz
right there
Apple is definitely trying to get as
much performance out of this machine as
they possibly can and I'm excited to see
the internals which we're gonna open up
in our comparison to the base model if
you guys want to see that we're about
90% done it's very interesting that
every one so I'll just actually is going
up to 3.1 gigahertz then down to 3 so as
a fans kicked up it's allowing it to run
faster the the wattage is now almost 31
watts so don't be fooled that 2
gigahertz I 5 when you're pushing it is
running at 3.0 3.1 and right now we're
about to get done here and we have a
score of 1708 personally I thought it
was gonna be higher because the
frequencies were staying up so high but
I guess we're gonna have to see how that
compares to the base model
which we'll do soon so there you go guys
as far as thermals it runs hot if you're
pushing it and it definitely is
preferring to run faster and hotter
Apple hasn't changed that with this
system and the frequencies stay pretty
dang high and this is 100% the whole
time so this is pushing it like crazy so
thank you guys for watching let me know
your thoughts down in the comments
section how to do as far as performance
and all of that stuff how about video
editing that was a massive difference
make sure you guys click that circle
above if you're not yet subscribed if
you are enable those notifications down
below this max and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]